[Musique]
bienvenue sur diagonale tv spéciale
leçon pour débutants avec nino maso a
dit bonjour nino bonjour bonjour à tous
alors avoir aujourd'hui un thème
fondamental aux déchets pour apprendre
bien les règles du jeu d'échecs et bien
les comprendre
c'est le concept de parties nulles
évidemment c'est très intéressant à
connaître il faut la connaître
ça peut être un moyen de sauver des
parties des fois il faut bien savoir
est-ce que telle ou telle position et on
peut conduire à la nulle pa on est donc
pour ça faut connaître les thèmes de
vraiment deux parties nulles un oui donc
il faut savoir qu elle
déjà il faut savoir qu elle pas tous les
partis dans la victoire
donc parfois on peut faire nul c'est à
dire un devoir pour chacun et après il
ya plusieurs possibilités dans le coma
vers nulle comme
il faut savoir que les positions
théoriques que ces campagnes
donc ça c'est essentiel à savoir dans
quelle position on ne peut pas on peut
pas gagner alors on va voir ça vacances
à tous après il existe donc nulle part
répétition de co en voir dans ce court
et il peut y avoir aussi plusieurs
façons qu'on va vous expliquer plus tard
voilà alors déjà première position si on
a droit contre mois déjà c'est nul
puisque le roi peuvent pas s'approcher
l'un de l'autre tout simplement parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit de se mettre en
échec
donc on va sauver un échec de l'autre
roi il n'a pas le droit en tant que ça
c'est une position la plus basique cas
possibles donc voilà si vous avez
d'euros qui restent il ya plus de pièces
voilà c'est évidemment c'est nul dans ce
cas la fois la partie s'arrête il n'ya
même pas on continue pas la partie on
joue pas le roi d'ailleurs ça c'est
intéressant
sachez que si par hasard votre
adversaire sera très surprenant mais il
veut pas faire nul vous avez absolument
droit d'appel et arbitres dans luis
attaque des positions dans l'impression
des nuls théorique et il va fixer
il va fixer et veut dire c'est une
partie nulle exactement
ouais non pas drôle choix l'arbitré
votre adversaire ne peut pas forcer le
gain donc il peut pas vous faire tomber
la pendule comme on dit donc là il c'est
nul forcé alors positions suivantes
séparer roi est fou contre roy
c'est une position nul on peut pas faire
maths avec rosneft info - faut moins de
pièces est pas le cas de la tour par
exemple c'était la tour saint perdon nez
avec le foot tout simplement non ça sera
pas avec le foot ne sais pas mais où va
vous pouvez réclamer l onu après
d'arbitré voilà parce que c'est
impossible de monter tout simplement
heureux même si vous faites exprès vous
pouvez pas vous faire mater pouvez
vérifier
il y aura toujours une quasi banques
pourquoi c'est important quand on commet
10,2
pourquoi faire intervenir leur vite
parce que comme on a du temps aux échecs
c'est finalement une certaine cadence
parfois quelqu'un peut essayer d'influer
votre temps est donc voué sur le temps
c'est pour ça si important savoir
qu'elle vous avez le droit s'adressait
aux arbitres là vous pouvez tout
simplement demandé la nulle et de façon
obligatoire on vous l'accordera alors
ensuite ici c'est la même chose c'est la
même chose d'ailleurs je crois même si
on tombe dans ses positions là où est on
peut pas maté s'est nouée oui c'est ça
faire quand même si vous tombez autant
en fait vous pouvez réclamer la nulle
parce que l'adversaire ne peut pas maté
sûr que si si vous reste donc trois
secondes vous jouez et puis finalement
ils voient chauriens la der sar pourrait
demander le gain sauf que si vous dites
mais non il peut pas y avoir guère
puisqu'il peut pas mater et bien
effectivement c'est nul il faut pouvoir
faut qu'ils aient un minimum de matériel
pour que le match soit possible même si
il ya de défense mais si le mat est
possible si vous êtes tombé alors dans
ce cas là oui vous rendre là si vous
voulez vous mettez cette position chez
vous vous essayez jouer même déplacer
les pièces sont celles où avec quelqu'un
d'autre
nous allons voir et pas de possibilité
de matane auto quoi qu'on fasse cavalier
son chien peut ainsi pas ça suffit pas
non plus alors ensuite roi y deux
cavaliers blé non plus en fait on peut
pas ça c'est pas ma télé deux cavalières
ça c'est ça c'est étonnant parce qu'on
se dit quand même de la gueule ici après
ouais mais en fait non on ne peut pas
faire vous pourrez essayer c on peut pas
on peut pas ma terrasse est une grande
exception vont pâtir parce que faire
exproprier sagan toujours aux échecs
sauf tout cas au lycée
c'est très grand avantage matériel mais
on arrive pas alors le problème c'est
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à pas d'être on
pourrait te placer derrière randy foye
de pièces vont montrer que le problème
c'est qu'elles le soient aussi au blanc
oui par exemple un peu importe le
problème c'est que le roi blanc tombe
dans le pas en fait ça va expliquer ce
que ça veut dire qu'on est dans le coin
qui est la position la plus facile à
priori à jouer on joue car elle a comme
seule oreille ne pas sortir sinon les
regarderons proches les ps par exemple
imaginons qu'on met ce cavalier ici on
s'est dit mais là on tient sûrement
faire maths comment c'est possible - au
regard des failles chez leurs péchés
donc là on est obligé de venir là et là
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait faire
un échec ici sur
roy sur une case noire or on voit bien
que c'était vallier il contrôle déjà la
case mans ici et j'attends d'eux car ils
étaient quatre pour tenter maths et s'y
fait voilà bien des ja pattes on peut
pas bouger et la croyance avait pas tout
ça mais c'est camilla panache et que le
roi n'avait pas bougé
et comme ce qu'elle ne peut pas faire il
peut s'il se caler bouge et comme une
surface blanche ici contrôle déjà avec
deux gazon peut pas contrôler en
bougeant il contrôle accru des cases
blanches dont il pourra pas faire échec
aux pattes c'est nul c nul des meilleurs
cavaliers s'approche chaque fois on
tombe sur les positions ou donc le roi
ton est à la pâte et ou pas approché
pour faire derniers chiffres et ces
différences il y avait en plus une
attention l'heure s'il est un pion ça
c'est très complexe on va vous expliquer
maintenant parce que débuter mais il
suffit qu'il est un pion de n'importe
quelle couleur ça change tout ça c'est
pas forcément gagnante mais ça dépend où
est le pion il ya plein de positions
théoriques 6 est sur b4 5 etc
mais ça peut changer tout parce que ça
paie imaginez s'il y avait un pion les
blancs jouent encore en course ont forcé
à jouer avec le pionnier après les noirs
profite pour moi de commencer sur la
position suivante
peut-être alors ici voilà fou contrefout
de même couleur
c'est nul lors des différentes on peut
encore faire maths mais il faut forcer
faut faut il faire exprès donc avoir une
certaine position où c'est vraiment
impossible de faire maths avec on s'en
fout et ce sera mais il faut savoir s'il
existe la position oui théoriquement on
vous pouvez perdre parfois mais contours
contre tours par exemple mais c'est
quand même se considérer comme nulles
théorique à vous avez droit de réclamer
la nuit là dans cette pollution même
c'était fou de couleur opposée où vous
avez droit de réclamer
bien sûr même de foot même mais
théoriquement vous pouvez encore faire
dans une position particulière vous
pouvez être pas mais il faudrait faire
exprès alors donc là c'est aussi des
positions deux nuls ça là ici alors ça
c'est le fameux truc comme ça faut le
connaître quand il ya un pion à ou h
comme ça si le roi adverse arrive à se
mettre sur la case ultime de promotion
ici s'ils arrivent à y aller mais on ne
peut pas gagner on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas déloger soir en fait la seule
chose à connaître ici il faut juste
rester un donc tellement le pion et
faire les cours regardez comment par
exemple c'est les blacks il faut d'abord
mais n'importe quoi par exemple et vous
jouez vous ne partez pas de notre côté
si on veut rester juste sur deux cases
en fait vous aideront à gérer trois
fuites mais c'est impossible à gagner
mais là c'est pas tout ça on ne peut pas
forcer le on peut pas forcer on peut pas
enlever le roi noir de cette case de
cases noires alors une autre grain
surprise quelque chose très étonnante à
la position suivante alors là ça s'est
un peu plus subtil mais là aussi c'est
nul alors pourquoi c'est alors en fait
c'est nul parce que le regarde et on a
toujours un pied aura donc on se dit
fictivement c'est pareil talent mais il
ya quand même un foot + on se dit ça
devrait suffire mais en fait non c'est
pas le bon fou parce qu'en fait il
faudrait le fou de cases blanches parce
qu'il faudrait c'est le fouquet's - vous
nous empêchez auriez le roi noir de
contrôler cette fameuse case de
promotion dont on vient de parler oui
donc que ça c'est très important à
connaître parce que sinon vous pourrez
tomber dans une pièce je suis un croyant
que c'est gagnant s'approche et regarder
le prime pourra pas empêcher le roi noir
de quitter cette case à 8 donc il va
simplement loin noir jouer sur scène il
a il va rester au contact
un militaire il va empêcher et comme il
reste dans le coin le bras blanc pourra
jamais l'embêter et le voit le fou non
plus donc on peut pas l'empêcher on peut
pas le faire quitter c'est parce qu'on
va continuer par exemple regardez par
exemple moi j'ai fait juste gérer ce
trop envie trois buts par exemple 20 mai
le gagner parce qu'elle soit ce sera pas
soit ils n'arrivent pas alors n'arrive
pas et décide t on pour faire impression
et là c'est pas toi y'a si on fait comme
ça le roi noyau plus bouger donc ses
pattes
ward est par contre sur la vie le foot
que ce blanche évidemment on aurait pu
faire les chèques et faire quitter leroy
lemoine man a remarqué que si le pied on
était sûr donc que l'on h
là ce sera
parce qu'elle s'attendait donc c'est une
autre couleur si on essaie l'autre cause
d ici on aurait le fou de la bonne
couleur juste à retenir casse de
promotion on doit être la même colère
qu'il faut voilà caisse de promotions
même couleur que le fou si on veut
gagner ou une version de défendre de
l'umq en l'occurrence si on cherche à
faire nul on est tranquille avait noirci
le fou la mauvaise couleur on peut faire
le don vous tombez faire les changes si
un échange vous donne ce type de
position et que vous voulez faire nul ou
défaite les changes
par exemple d'armes contre dame vous
échanger les dames sachant que moi de
l'annuler leur geste et je savais les
parties comme ça j'ai su urbain parce
que oui quand j'étais môme forte saison
oui il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui ne
connaissent pas finalement des bus
survenu et certains on va la laissant
pas même cinq pièces vous pouvez faire
nulle part c'est un truc à connaître si
le fou n'est pas de la couleur des
approbations juste je voulais ajouter un
mot remarqué qu est là il faut jouer
comme juste si vous partez avec le roi
complètement à hier il va faire
promotionne donc faites attention où ils
savent pas forcément non plus le roi
noir avec les abus sur ce très loin
évidemment le pion va très vite adam
même là si vous jouez mal si au lieu de
vous diriger vers le kiosque vous
voudrez dans ailleurs comme si vous
allez leur exemple ça c'est pas une
bonne idée parce que là laurent blanc
peut aller vous empêchez par exemple il
vous empêche de revenir si vous jouez là
au pradet le fou va bloquer et ça y est
vous pouvez plus passer wii board et
vous ayez une sorte de barrière en kaki
forme est là le pion il va pouvoir y
aller donc évolué au jeu juste il faut
juste savoir quel roi ou empereur
ramener en urgence dans le coin il faut
absolument dément le client va l'arrêter
c'est seulement que le roi ait contrôlé
cette case de promotion
un autre exemple donc c'est un exemple
tout simple donc tour contre tours là
aussi c'est nul maintenant on peut pas
forcer le match roy tour contre wigan
mais évidemment si l'autre vers sert à
une tour ça fait nul la seule
possibilité perdre et si c'est par
hasard les célèbres voix là par hasard
mais sinon c'est vous pouvez demander là
nul oui c'est considérer comme nulles
théorique
alors ici on va voir un autre cas de nul
c'est là nulle part répétition de coûts
ont quelque chose de vraiment la
connaître
alors on regarde une petite partie 400
cavaliers
3 qu'est ce que ça veut dire que les c6
à répétition de cours où ces cas où
c'est simple petit rock cavaliers petit
rock la fougue 3 et les noirs juifs ou
2,6 et imaginant que votre adversaire ou
vous je ne sais pas très bien poussé
quatre c4 s'est pas forcément très bons
coups mais et les noirs jouent la même
chose tous ses singles donc là ça fait
deux fois qu'on voit la même position
parce que on vient de voir alors si on
répète en fait trois fois la même
position
là on peut demander la lune tendent
comment ça se passait juste fait
attention vraiment parce que il faut
donner le nuc juste avant de lui donc ça
c'est important à savoir parfois vous
pouvez penser que si je fais troisième
fois c'est automatiquement nul ne s'est
pas automatiquement un nul soit on vous
proposait d'ailleurs auxerre peut-être
ils vont accepter et vu qu'il répète
aussi les coûts oui mais sinon si vous
n'êtes pas sûrs parce que vous savez
parfois on répète le couple organise du
terme aux échecs parfois on nous on a
problème de taille t-notes on n'a pas
suffisamment tôt m
c'est pour ça on répète donc si on n'est
pas sûr et ça vous arrange nul dans
telle ou telle position à moins de jouer
troisième coup il faut surtout pas jouer
si vous jouez ses coûts après vous a plu
droits demandés nuit avant de le jouer
arrêter là par la rue et vous appelez
les arbitres et vous dites moi jeanne
usage faire tel ou tel cook est donc
dans cette position de répression hélas
il n'a fait que c'est nul mais si vous
faites
après donc votre tour est passé en c'est
trop tard voilà il faut demander avant
de répéter la troisième fois là ça fait
deux fois la même position s'il est
blanc répète encore four b3 b6 donc si
vous vous trompez qu'est ce qui se passe
si vous demandez par exemple ici le nul
ce serait juste au foie donc la foule c4
n'est toujours pas là placé au noir de
jouer voilà c'est les noirs qui doivent
demander la nullissime we see
nous y voilà si ça vous de jouer donc si
les noirs juifs ou c5
ça fera donc
trois fois la même position ça fait
trois fois de suite que les que les fous
sont mêmes conditions on a ce cas là les
noirs avant de jouer doivent demander à
un arbitre
voilà je peux jouer plus et 5 ça va
peut-être à trois fois la position donc
joue également de la nulle la retraite
obligée de vous l'accordé voilà par
contre si vous jouez sans demander les
blancs sont pas obligés de répéter
oui par exemple ils ont joué je lave
linge ou un autre coup on voit la joue
rachat donc c'est fini on peut plus
demander la nullité faites tout de suite
mais ce qui est intéressant de continuer
par exemple vous aussi vous feront
ensuite là aussi par exemple on en
comprend la peau prélevé nkufo b3 b6 et
imaginons qu'il revient maintenant avec
le roi roger et là encore une fois vous
pouvez même ici des modèles quoi parce
que voilà oui vous pouvez si vous jouez
roi g8 ni mail il y aura trois pole
positions cette foire et les fous sur
les cases b3 b6 mais surtout c'est qu'il
faudrait tenir beaucoup tient de croix
et se trompe et ses propositions ça doit
être enchaîné c'est à dire trois
positions qui se répètent tout de suite
ensemble en fait oui non mais c'est pas
ça ça peut être même un terrain de 20
coups en fait bien sûr d'aller finir ça
arrive vous savez mais attention il faut
pas par exemple que il ya la possibilité
du rock dans une position et pas dans
l'autre c'est à dire que c'est dans les
trois positions qui sont équivalentes
il y en a une ou vous pouvez roke est
que dans l'autre vous vous demandez là
nul vous pouvez pas ok c'est pas là
c'est pas considérer voilà c'est pas
considérer que la même position
voilà alors que pourtant c'est
matériellement la même mais enfin on
peut pas faire une exception une
exception mais voilà ici donc si les
noirs jouent au roi g8
il y aura trois fois la même position
avec deux fous ici vous pouvez voir le
truc effectivement il peut y avoir des
coups d'intervalle c'est ce que tu
expliques iplayer vincou d'intervalle
entre les deux et j'ai vu déjà les
parties sauvé
au niveau de mai très grande m dans les
finales ou par exemple ils on va
peut-être fois et après ils ont joué
très longtemps j'en pense qu après est
un des adversaires très marquée à ça se
répète même après 15 courses et le
troisième fois il sauve la partie grâce
à ça alors que tu as vraiment si t'as
perdu
on va voir une autre positive sinon
juste prêté attention il se fit bouger
un pilote ça change tout ça sera plus la
même position sur surjoue langue il faut
pas penser qu'elle sait juste les unes
c'est le ps qui se répète
non c'est juste position d'un tiers en
général faut pas bouger les tubes ce que
tu ne peuvent pas revenir sur leur casse
donc on peut pas répéter les positions
en bougeant les pions alors f10 saf a
rien ici c'est aux blancs de jouer alors
ça c'est là nulle part échec perpétuelle
mais ce bond échec perpétuerait ça
revient à répéter les positions on dit
que c'est mais c'est pareil parce que ça
veut dire si on fait chic habituels
qu'on peut forcer trois fois la même
position
c'est pas autre chose donc ici c'est mon
préféré
on préfère dire ces chiffres habituels
parce que mais c'est pareil alors donc
qu'on fait mais en force on force un
adversaire de faire trois fois trois
fois une position on dit qu'en général
ces accords mutuels des deux joueurs
ces volontaires alors que l'as les noirs
là il aimerait bien continuer puisque
ils ont quand même une tour de plus mais
les blancs trouve échec par cet échec et
ils peuvent faire trois fois la même
position en faisant tout simplement
chaque perpétuelle c'est vrai qu'elle
s'est en même temps mais j'espère plus
nulle part par les pétitions répétition
ces répétitions deux coups en fait on
dit perpétuelle mais non parce que au
bout de trois fois la même position peut
demander la nullité c'est pas la peine
de le faire perpétuellement alors on
voit la suite
donc voilà ici c'est ashley perpétuelle
ici là c'est pareil chez perpétuée par
par le cavalier regardez là les blancs
sont pas très bien puisqu'ils sont quand
même
bertand ils sont mal mais il se trouve a
décrit perpétuelle donc ils vont répéter
trois fleurs d'imposition par échec
perpétuelle par échec roi g8 et au
regard des échecs et le roi peut pas
sortir puisque le cavalier protège donc
obligé de revenir ensuite il suffit de
revenir faire échec mais on va faire
voilà ça va faire trois fois la même
position donc échec perpétuelle aussi
dans cette position donc voyez on n'est
pas obligé de le faire avec la dame on
le faire aussi avec un cavalier
oui c'est son ça se passe avec la dame
ça aurait besoin simple dames
impuissante mais alors on peut voir que
oui et ça peut être avec le cavalier
bleu fou et c'est alors la police on va
voir plusieurs exemples ici si
lecavalier on va en maintenant avec le
fou regarde un peu aussi faire les
chèques perpétuel avec le fou oui ici
les bleus manquent tellement de pièces
mais il arrive quand même intervenu on
est mal avec les blancs mais regardez là
il se trouve que la position
particulière est fou et s'inquiète le
roi est obligé d'aller sur la case g8 le
pion f6 empêche le roi nice au
classement et la regarder fou aux six
échecs encore et on est obligé de
revenir sur la canne achète donc c'est
facile avec le moins surpris de répéter
ces voix là et là c'est vous forcez
trois fois la même position
on appelle ça aussi chez perpétuelle
mais voilà c'est pareil et donc c'est
nul donc il faut faire très attention
parce que c'est souvent quand même on
sauve les parties où nos adversaires
savent les parties quand c'est possible
c'est très très courant oui parfois on
rate on a même vraiment très très grand
avantage il ya la dame qui arrive ou
s'apprêtent à le payer c'est échec échec
on n'a pas vu obs trop tard on n'a pas
vu qu'on pouvait on ne peut pas
s'échapper et l'adversaire à la chine ça
c'est pas bon alors on voit la suite ici
là c'est pareil alors c'est un échec
perpétuel où est très très subtil alors
impôt régional un peu original donc tout
à fait intéressant à regarder échec au
roi
et si le roi revient sur la 90e il y
aura pas chez portugal puisque sir fait
chèque je vais prendre la tour mais non
parce que cavalier 3 regardez ces
superbes puisque le cavalier attaque le
roi est emmerdant prête protège la
condition qu'on ne peut pas donc obligé
de revenir et si on fait échec si on
essaie de s'échapper de l'autre côté ou
h 2 on revient chez qui le dit bon ok si
je reviens à sa fille perpétuelle mais
on se dit donc dans ce cas là on dit je
vais venir en h
mais là ça serait pas ce serait une
mauvaise nouvelle pour
non parce qu'on a le fameux match et pas
comme on l'appelle celui-là mais enfin
c'est un match maintenant que j'ai
croisés si je crois qu'il ya un nom j'ai
principalement des jeux c'est pas bon
bref le cas ici regardez seimat
regardez le roi ne peut pas voilà donc
en fait la bonne solution pour les
lancers de revenir effectivement sur
leur travail et d'accepter bella nulle
part échec perpétuelle en terrain voilà
sinon on perd carrément la partie d'un
coup voyez quelqu'un exemple on va voir
voilà ça c'est bien
oui je crois qu'on a vu tous les
exemples ici deux nuls classique les
positions standard donc les chiffres par
pays qu elle est effectivement c'est le
sait le plus courant et après évidemment
c'est l'absence de matériel en fait
toutes les autres cas on a vu roi
contrepoids roi fou contre eux rouaroua
que la vallée compte trois rois autour
contreras tour tout s'annule même râteau
contrepoids fou aussi nuls 1 d'ailleurs
le nom autant qu'entre roi fou aura tous
contre roye cavaliers sont nuls aussi
donc traiter les cas aujourd'hui nous on
a vu les
logique donc les positions théoriques
teigneux on a vu également donc
perpétuelle par répétition le nul et
sachez qu'il existe donc par pat on
aurait parlé d'ailleurs et par
consentement aussi il faut dire tout
simplement vous proposer une offre donc
là il ya les petits règle à respecter
tout simplement des politesses
pratiquement de ne pas partir ou pas
votre adversaire par harceler par
proposer les nuls parfois ça arrive
aussi qu'il faut éviter de proposer
moins trois fois la nuit déjà c'est ça
des gens bien après vous n'a pas droit
normalement dès proposé lui pendant
qu'il réfléchisse c'est pas si longtemps
que ça se passe vous faites un coût et
en même temps vous proposez nous serons
encore voilà ça j'ai joué votre cou et
avant d'appuyer sur la pendule burundi
est tout simple je propose nul et vous
appuyez sur la pendule
donc vous dites tout simplement âgées
vous propose nul et il va vous dire que
oui juste accord ou juste pas d'accord
je préfère la continuer voilà voilà donc
il faut éviter les faux pas harceler
l'adversaire donc trois fois nul c'est
déjà beaucoup et donc ne dépassez pas
trois propositions nul surtout sur votre
adversaire est censé être plus fort
ça peut être très d'abord c'est mal vu
si vous proposez nu alors
la position n'est pas forcément si vous
êtes très très perdant c'est pas très
poli d'un salaire de recettes ific
d'agir je sais pas pourquoi mais ça
c'est souvent ça se passe donc il faut
éviter il faut éviter faut accepter de
perdre rien aux échecs voilà c'est aussi
la règle donc voilà c'est cette leçon
très importante pour le jeu d'échecs
évidemment toutes ces notions de parties
nulles qui est le résultat le plus le
plus court en l'annulant finalement
celui qui arrive le plus souvent annotés
partie externe voilà presque la moitié
des partis au moins qui se termine par
nu et le reste qui se termine en gains
ou des fêtes voilà merci nino pour cette
leçon sur la nulle aux échecs voilà
merci à bientôt pour redresser une autre
leçon pour débutants sur diagonale tv au
revoir
[Musique]